bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue ici
au parc floral pour ces deux magnifiques
journées qui vont rassembler plus de
1500 jeunes merci d'être au rendez vous
merci à la jeunesse de rendre aussi
fiers notre famille politique vous êtes
notre fierté vous êtes notre espoir pour
l'avenir l'espoir de la droite
républicaine mais aussi l'espoir de la
france l'espoir de notre pays et c'est
de notre pays dont il va être question
durant ces deux journées vous aurez la
parole comme vous l'avez eu l'année
dernière au port marly on est heureux de
pouvoir renouveler cet événement autour
de la nouvelle équipe qui aujourd'hui
même le destin des jeunes républicains
et je le redis je vous le redis au nom
de tous merci de votre mobilisation
soyez fiers de vos valeurs soyez fiers
de nos convictions et soyez fiers de ce
que vous allez faire pour l'avenir je
vous demande d'accueillir à présent les
deux personnalités qui vont ouvrir ces
deux journées ici au parc floral je vous
demande d'abord d'accueillir le
président des républicains celui qui
depuis désormais plusieurs années
tiennent notre maison et notre famille
politique celui bien su rassembler notre
famille politique celui qui a su unir
notre famille politique celui qui depuis
des mois avec constance et détermination
nous pousse à travailler à un projet
d'avenir et d'espoir pour les françaises
et les français celui qui sait ce que la
fidélité et le courage en politique
veulent dire je vous demande
d'accueillir notre président christian
jacob
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et oui mais on m'a donné le micro s'est
terminé ton temps de parole est écoutée
écoulée ouais ouais c'est vrai quel
micro c'est plus toi
donc écouter on va maintenant faire
venir à nos côtés guilhem carayon votre
président abonde m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vraiment
le président
m
[Musique]
formidable alain storrer bien vous
disais que nous saurions 2500 on est à
plus de 1500 inscrits et ça c'est la
dynamique c'est la mobilisation cette
formidable équipe des jeunes bravo à toi
bravo à ton équipe et bravo au travail
réalisé depuis un an
alors oui pour la france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors les amis on va commencer qu'il
aime va vous dire un mot dans donc dans
une minute moi ce que je voulais vous
dire à la suite d'un aurélien depuis
deux ans
tout d'abord dans les objectifs j'avais
annoncé en devenant président notre
famille politique c'était celui de
constituer un grand mouvement de
jeunesse pour l'ancien président des
jeunes agriculteurs les organisations de
jeunesse comme ça c'est pas toujours
facile
mais c'était important qu'une famille
politique comme la nôtre nous avec la
jeunesse ils l'ont lancé l'année
dernière ils sont venus une élection
interne qui s'est formidablement bien
passé avec une belle mobilisation avec
une belle volonté de rassemblement qui
est une réalité aujourd'hui tous les
jeunes républicains sont rassemblés et
puis la mobilisation vous êtes là et
maintenant on va passer effectivement à
l'étape d'après c'est à dire qu'il
fallait créer ce mouvement de jeunesse
qu'est créée il fallait ensuite
travailler sur le fond et je vais
revenir dans un instant mais il fallait
aussi montré que les républicains
étaient de retour et nous sommes de
retour nous sommes de retour parce que
depuis deux ans on a enchaîné les
victoires électorales les unes après les
autres ça a été les municipales
ça a été les sénatoriales madame et
messieurs les sénateurs qui sont déjà
arrivés ça a été les législatives
partielles ça a été les départementales
ces télés régionales à un combat
électoral depuis deux ans ne nous a
échappé
maintenant on est effectivement
[Musique]
on est maintenant sur la dernière ligne
droite
la clé de voûte de nos institutions
l'élection présidentielle et pour
l'élection présidentielle
journaliste pour poser mais ils sont
très peu à s'interroger là-dessus la
question du candidat
mais je pense cette question va avoir
l'occasion d'y venir simplement il faut
aussi faire la démonstration aux
français qu'après avoir montré qu'on
était capable de gérer les collectivités
territoriales porter des projets qui
répondait aux attentes de nos
concitoyens il faut que nous fassions la
même chose sur le plan national et c'est
la raison pour laquelle depuis deux ans
nous avons fait ce formidable travail
sur le fond avec bien entendu tous nos
militants jeunes et moins jeunes mais
aussi avec la mobilisation formidable de
nos parlementaires le travail qu'ils
font dans les groupes parlementaires et
nous aurons l'occasion d'accueillir de
nos présidents de nos présidents de
groupe les différentes propositions
loire mais aussi les avis de différents
experts que nous avons reçu des
représentants de la société civile et
puis ensemble nous avons fait ce travail
c'est plus de 200 réunions qui se sont
tenues au siège des républicains 90%
visio pour les raisons que vous imaginez
bien et à chaque fois on a sorti des
propositions très concrètes et chacune
des propositions qui était présente et a
été soumis au vote des militants par une
proposition n'est retenu s'il n'a pas
été validé par un vote effectif des
militants voilà comment on a construit
notre notre programme et voilà
maintenant où nous en sommes alors ce
travail les jeunes se sont appropriés
ils ont aussi réagi face à cela ils vont
avoir l'occasion de nous dire là où il y
a des manques là où il faut le corriger
là il faut faire d'autres propositions
donc c'est tout l'intérêt de ces deux
jours et du travail qu'ils ont réalisé
en amont donc voila moi simplement les
quelques mots que je voulais vous dire
un dernier peut-être ou avant-dernier
même sur nos victoires électorales
il ya quelqu'un que je voudrais saluer
en particulier ici parce qu'il incarne
cette ce renouvellement à cette victoire
c'est le président du conseil
départemental du val de marne olivier
capitanio
il nous accueille chez lui
olivier dans ce département
ils ont gagné après 45 ans de communisme
si vous voulez avoir une leçon sur
l'organisation sur l'unité sur le
rassemblement sur la capacité de faire
l'union vous pouvez regarder dans le
val-de-marne parce qu'ils ont su le
faire et en ne mettant jamais leur
drapeau dans leur poche lorsque olivier
qui après avoir été élu à 75% au premier
tour aux municipales dans sa ville de
maisons alfort lorsqu'il a succédé à
michel herbillon il a ils ont gagné le
département et il est le président de la
fédération et l'heure du val de marne et
croyez moi que son drapeau et jamais
dans la poche il est en vue tout le
monde bravo olivier nous accueillir dans
son département
alors maintenant pendant ces deux jours
tout est ouvert à la presse parce que
vous savez moi je suis de c'est que
quand on commence à tenir des secrets à
trois personnes ça tient rarement
longtemps donc à 1700 ça me semblait
compliqué donc tout est ouvert à la
presse partout n'y a pas de filtre nulle
part vous avez à voir je crois qu'on a
une centaine de journalistes qui sont
qui sont inscrits il nous aime beaucoup
ils sont très inquiets pour nous ils
s'inquiètent beaucoup de notre santé
donc vous allez les rassurer ils vont
nous prendre le pouls régulièrement
montré leur tournée en forme les
républicains sont de retour et que les
jeunes sont là
[Applaudissements]
chers amis c'est avec une très grande
joie que je vous retrouve aujourd'hui
aussi nombreux au parc floral
aujourd'hui vous êtes plus de mille cinq
cent mille 500 jeunes républicains et
rien que pour ça je vous demande de vous
accueillir très très fort
sim le permettez je voudrais d'abord
adressé un remerciement chaleureux à
notre président christian jacob qui
depuis deux ans et son arrivée à la tête
des républicains à rassembler notre
famille politique à mener un travail de
reconstruction aussi bien idéologique
que de terrain avec la reprise en main
de toutes les fédérations
départementales de notre mouvement le
résultat il est clair on a gagné toutes
les élections depuis les européennes les
départementales et régionales les
municipales et les sénatoriales bravo
président maintenant cap sur la
présidentielle pour redresser le pays
redresser la france
président vous aussi vous adresser notre
notre amitié et notre soutien parce que
vous avez pris confiance pris conscience
de l'intérêt de la jeunesse grâce à vous
les jeunes républicains sont autonome
l'autonomie des jeunes républicains
c'était un sujet sur la table depuis de
longues années aujourd'hui c'est chose
faite nous sommes au travail merci
président encore une fois
[Applaudissements]
chers amis depuis avril et notre arrivée
à la tête des jeunes républicains on n'a
pas ménagé nos efforts la première
priorité pour nous ça a été de renforcer
notre ancrage territorial dès notre
arrivée on a nommé 35 nouveaux rdj et
désormais il ya des rdj dans toutes les
fédérations de france toutes les
fédérations de france on rdj c'est une
première depuis dix ans et je voulais
remercier
[Applaudissements]
nous avons nous avons aussi nommer des
délégués régionaux qui ont fait un
travail immense pendant tout l'été pour
mobiliser pour faire que cet événement
soit un grand succès je vais aussi les
remercier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour ma part j'ai déjà visité 50
fédérations à part départementale depuis
avril et je compte bien y retourner dès
la semaine prochaine parce qu'il faut
aller partout il faut aller mobiliser
gagné voix par voie pour redresser pays
et gagner l'élection présidentielle
notre priorité chers amis c'est aussi
mené un travail sur le fond pour qu'il y
ait une reconstruction idéologique
c'est pour cette raison qu'on a entamée
avec christian jacob ainsi que les deux
propositions ces propositions elles vous
seront dévoilés demain par théo michel
secrétaire général des jeunes
républicains et par marie glinel qui est
la présidente du sac l'athéna ces
propositions c'est les propositions des
jeunes républicains pour la présentielle
gens tous les thèmes qui intéressent la
jeunesse les questions d'immigration de
sécurité d'emploi des jeunes d'écologie
tout ça on les a pris en compte on a des
propositions et elles vous seront
dévoilés demain
le résultat chers amis il est net il ya
six mois il y avait 1500 jeunes
républicains aujourd'hui on est un
mouvement de dix mille jeunes
républicains dix mille jeunes
républicains on est redevenu le premier
mouvement politique de jeunes en france
ça c'est grâce à vous bravo à vous
j'ai maintenant vous présenter le
nouveau bureau national des jeunes
républicains qui a été élu en avril
je vous demande et du coup de lever la
main pour que vous soyez identifié à
chacun je vous appelle alors charlotte
vaio qui est vice présidente des jeunes
républicains et qui est adjointe à la
mairie de nemours seine-et-marne tchèque
les soldats club
théo michel qui est secrétaire général
des jeunes républicains qui est
fiscaliste et qui est conseiller du
xviie arrondissement de paris
et de ses moulins qui est trésorière du
mouvement et qui est la responsable déjà
les flics n la marne
guillaume gabriel responsable des jeunes
républicains des hauts-de-seine est en
charge de la communication du mouvement
irène weiss 22 ans et plus jeune
conseiller régional de france
[Musique]
bastien dauphin responsable des jeunes
républicains du nord et qui a été
candidat au départemental à lille dans
un coin très compliqué bras vols
à la demande sourit qui est responsable
des jeunes républicains de l'isère
l'isère qui est venu en masse
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
alexandre d'espèces qui est régi ancien
pdg de la drôme maintenant trésorier la
fédération et qui est ingénieur en
plasturgie
alexandra monnaie notre spécialiste de
la culture
travaille à 90 aux côtés de laurence
garnier kg lutte à leur
accès axel nous ferons pardon r d chez
la côte d'or en charge des relations
internationales du mouvement
géré vitaly responsable des jeunes
républicains de la vendée et qui en
apprentissage à la fns noir il s'occupe
de la formation du mouvement et de cette
école de formation qu'on va monter
génie nasa responsable et je n'avais
plus qu'un des sublimes
directrice de cabinet de jo croit badge
de keating qui est le plus jeune maire
et l'air d'île de france
quentin kermen étudiants en sciences
politiques l'organisateur de l'équipe la
pièce maîtresse du mouvement des jeunes
actifs
victoria tédeschi et l'actrice une pme à
paris
candidate aux côtés de rachida dati dans
le 12e arrondissement
pierre fontaine élus à versailles aux
côtés de françois de mazières
et pour finir quentin tayeb responsable
des jeunes républicains du rhône et qui
est également venu en force au bac loire
le rhône bravo
merci à toute l'équipe merci pour votre
mobilisation immense ges maintenant la
parole à aurélien pradié secrétaire
général du mouvement et à quillan guérin
mais avant ça on va vous passez une
courte vidéo sur nos victoires ou
départementales et aux régionales merci
à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]